okay so lesson number one let's see on a
numeric una cha meet young power right
repeat with me me me yeah yeah and then
you see your sister I'm sure you
couldn't save power as you see literally
it means hello I call myself uh my name
is I'm cold like this and typically we
do not put the subject you could say yo
me llamo but typically you don't want to
do it unless you want to emphasize who
you are to me Johnny
she'll kill Mon Chou me llamo Ileana
okay now let's do this
I say me llamo Paola and then I ask you
call me young friend stand up you say me
llamo Anita and you want somebody else
with you can okay so coming again the
camera needs this going to kill me ciao
Miki Ando Ileana ah how we can wall
Clara come at me help
she's a second I know many of you speak
Spanish so you tend to say poco me yeah
let's try it all together momentum yes
good Tiamo
Esther
well yeah power gets it literally means
pleasure nice to meet you oh thanks
repeat okay yeah yeah chit chit hey Tim
good far back so as you might have
noticed we pronounced flat first
different from the English let's start
first of all to see how we pronounce
neat balance so we have and whoo whoo so
forget say you oh yes excellent
listen now this seems simple it's a
little bit more tricky we also use
accents so we have two kinds of absence
we have a great
accent in Italian is grab it so it
spends the same way but you pronounce it
differently
I've China to grab it and it's an accent
this direction from the top to the
bottom and then we have acute accent a
chain come off
so what's the difference well for
example if I write and I put a great
accent I pronounce it is phat it's open
right that's right if I say why it's
okay it's close you see the friends can
you get here yep so cut back yes now
most of the words actually have great
accents and even the words that have
cute accents most of the times are
pronounced by Italians as if the
accident was brain was open so when I
say the kid I would say attack nobody
will complain everybody understands the
only people will complain are the people
from the academia de la Cruz cup so a
[ __ ] who's got means a Academy of the
brand and of a beard name and it was
founded founded in the 16th century
my goodness scholars of linguists who
wanted you to develop the pure Italian
Italian it comes from lighting and then
the world there were a lot of regional
dialects then these scholars in the in
Tuscany Florence you select them they
decided no we want to decide what is
real pure Italian why this group and
only academia del anushka the academy of
brand and the name comes from the fact
that when you sift you don't want to
divide the flour wheat flour from the
low quality friend you do this process
of of the value of safety so they wanted
to provide the bed italian from the good
high quality Italian so back to our
accents here we have a game bowels is
the Sun kind of just saying rapo
we will go from A to E and then from up
- oh and you will see why because if I
say ah my mouth is completely open ah
now I have the letter threes the ridge
accent ah and then I close my mouth a
little bit more and then the last one is
T my mouth
all right so it goes from very open ah
same comes from up top together
ah let's try again
all together and then hear all the
voices are really really important
especially at the end of the work that's
where we Oh another small thing I told
you that there is a grave and then a
cute absent but again most Italians they
will write a fat with something that's
like this although it should be the
great accent but with a handwriting we
don't really pay too much attention
okay so you don't have to worry that
much as long as pronounce it correctly
don't say carpet of this company doesn't
affect so for example did you say haha
without an accent
it means the Pope if you write ha ha
that means that so there is a huge
difference between the Pope right are to
say you know well para is that a pear
tree it's a tree
you say at all well they're all is a
good negation it means that or however
so let's try to read these words so with
the accent
since there is no accent here we put the
accent on the first syllable papa
yeah you can also put this just to
remind yourself ha ha yeah ha ha ha ha
ha feel little bit up hello
yes let's try to introduce the numbers
probably notice the to try tends to move
right into our hands but and any time it
when we count we count in a different
way so we start with uno and this is one
no no do it good that like in the US a
week this is 2 right nobody understands
me when I say this is do it so let's
write this down now here's something
very what
so you see we have a double consonant
and it's extremely important this is
like one of the biggest and most common
errors of foreigners who try to speak
Italian is to forget that's we have
double tassels and change from single
concern to a double consonant you change
completely the meaning of what you're
saying so let's say again what's wrong
yeah so you spend a little bit more time
lateral cheating Cinque yes chief we're
so here for those of you who speak
Spanish you can probably get well we
pronounce
wait wait wait chi-ching wait yeah geez
Jim wait wait oh just remember the gt1
to say
another double then for example if I say
save it without TT it means that a
thirst o Satan means I'm thirsty okay so
this is sector a very different from say
today and now we have another one up Oh
No yeah ooh no cheese 100g energy good
so that was our extremely important
again if you say
papa that's the phone
they are very Catholic country diffusing
the pop up as an example if you put the
double and Papa means food makes you
keep weight like here talking to a
little baby you say it just eat this
Papa but for sometimes you want you want
to use it if if something looks like
baby food like if you read food that it
doesn't look very tasty then you say
well what's this Papa Papa [ __ ]
boundaries big difference for Nona
that means nice the ninth season for
example
well becomes known and not enough is
yeah so no no no no yes very good now we
will soon start to cook I promise
but before we do that let's try to learn
in Valois Cucina which emotions to cook
so we start with the indicative of
present
that's the kind indicative presence of
the verb which in added she like you
chamber she nah today in Italian we have
verbs that end with different
combinations so we have the verbs like
kannada the end in add we have verbs
like bed
and to drink and the equity area and
then we have verbs like don't need to
see the end with either your coochie not
be a babe don't need a blow here so
verbs that end with are they would
conjugate like to her yeah
murder can be heated air a take on you
guys like better person and in here this
is it contagious
so they we've kind of get like the verb
the meter then we have a lot of
exceptions you think you can still try
to work we learn all the way we want to
know first how the regular is with dirt
behave so let's go back to our very
generic the seven-week we have to
achieve we are Cucina as I told you
usually we just neglect the subject so I
wrote it in parentheses typically I will
not say you would she know I just say
put you okay and in order to remember in
the accent you can clap your hands right
so yo
okay - to see you see they all have the
same Aditi and then we change the end
based on subject so in English you say I
cook yokel
she cooks like you just add one has
please eat and then we cook again oh you
look the same and then cook that's
boring oh good we like to change the end
for every subject so yeah she to ruin
for life so nuit is masculine and like
honey hey nice - little bit different
no yeah boy boy you which happened Laura
Cucina she's between yeah a very common
error is to say Poochyena now you can
say she okay so how about we can go
around you don't have to be don't work
you don't pronounce it
whatever it's like the first half an
hour Italian in your life so we can just
go around and read through so anything
you can start with me cooking chi-ching
chi-ching
this is the first one that's different
is Fujiyama yeah it's tricky right
because the the others say yo [ __ ] you
have the accent of the eye on de
chiloe chile china and i changes coach
in yahoo Jinyoung yes Gina Gina is here
the game
you